ribot fin de la reunión pre cop 26 en
italia a un mes de la cumbre climática
de glasgow las delegaciones llegaron a
la conclusión de que hay que hacer más
para combatir la crisis climática
we need to enhance keeping hubo consenso
en que necesitamos hacer más
colectivamente en términos de nuestros
compromisos en términos de
contribuciones y varias partes señalaron
que obviamente depende de todos nosotros
pero particularmente de las naciones del
g20 que representan el 80 por ciento de
las emisiones
[Música]
en esta línea los 50 representantes
ambientales acordaron mayores esfuerzos
para mantener el calentamiento global
por debajo de los 15 grados centígrados
y coincidieron en la necesidad de lanzar
un paquete de 100 mil millones de
dólares anualmente para ayudar a las
naciones más vulnerables frente al
cambio climático de materializarse esta
ayuda no llegaría hasta después de 2025
a pesar del mal pronóstico ambiental
algunos delegados
optimistas
la conclusión es amigos que tal y como
estamos hoy aquí podemos hacer grandes
progresos en glasgow avanzando
rápidamente hacia los nuevos objetivos
que la ciencia nos dice que debemos
alcanzar charangas windscheif el
preludio de la cop 26 coincidió con las
manifestaciones de jóvenes
ambientalistas reunidos en la cumbre de
rufo climate exigen a los gobiernos
mundiales más acciones para frenar la
crisis climática